tonios Policía Municipal desde hace 22
años pero para poder pagar sus facturas
ha recurrido a su viejo maletín de
peluquería para nuevamente hacer cortes
de pelo a domicilio
dijiste oficio porque creí que ser
funcionario era más seguro con una
seguridad social y jubilación ahora con
lo que me pagan no es suficiente para
cubrir los gastos mínimos de mi familia
así que hago esto en mis días libres
el municipio de Villa es la tercera
ciudad más grande del Líbano pero de la
seguridad se encargan solo Tony es
compañero asi Quién es el más veterano y
una decena de agentes locales somos dos
oficiales fijos y cubrimos todo el área
hacemos de todo y nuestro salario son
extremadamente bajos como funcionario
público no se me permite aplicar para
otro trabajo de esta alcaldía depende de
los pueblos vecinos pero recortes y la
normativa que impide nuevo
reclutamientos de funcionarios públicos
desde 2019 los deja desprovistos de la
seguridad la municipalidad de devi sigue
haciendo todo lo posible en estos
tiempos difíciles Aunque tengamos que
asumir otras responsabilidades por falta
de personal El colapso Financiero
agudiza las tensiones sociales que
aumenta la criminalidad para ello tomas
valenta Apuesta por mejorar la
capacitación de estos agentes y
garantizar la sostenibilidad como
objetivos del programa europeo de
policía de proximidad del que es miembro
hay una palabra muy bonita en inglés
public worker que significa que toda
persona que trabaja en un organismo
encargado de hacer cumplir la ley está
al servicio de los ciudadanos para poder
ofrecer el mejor servicio a los
ciudadanos las agencias de seguridad
deben cooperar entre sí sin embargo las
diferencias hectáreas del carácter
oligárquico del sistema libanés
dificultan las colaboraciones entre la
policía los consejos municipales y la
sociedad civil este espacio de discusión
contribuye a mejorar la percepción mutua
el crimen y la delincuencia crecen
aprovechando la brecha de la crisis
económica sin unas fuerzas de seguridad
preparadas y con sueldos insuficientes
se empieza a comparar
donde la criminalidad se ha disparado
sin precedentes desde 2019